alright I'm so glad to be here this is
such a great surprise I bet you all are
surprised to so who all has ever made a
comment to themselves as they were
coding within their code itself
everybody in the room I'm so glad you're
here um so there could be a lot of
reasons for that and since we're such a
small room like maybe we want to like
shout back at each other and do stuff
like that do we feel good about that
like why would you make that comment to
yourself future you you might have like
a variable that you're like oh shoot I
want to keep this short but I'm not
really super good at naming variables
yet you may have done that whole
copy-paste section of code from Stack
Overflow and how does it really work
you're not super sure anybody else do
that just me all right all right we got
a couple folks um and you want to take
care of that future self as somebody
mentioned but when you made that last
comment to yourself did you think that
you were writing documentation we we
don't want to be there in that bottom
frame and documentation is what allows
our code to be used expanded and adapted
and for community hopefully at some
point we all dream of community being
formed around our little baby projects
so when you last wrote that comment into
your code you're probably making a note
of something that you thought wasn't
clear at the time or might be unclear in
the future um but sometimes we don't
think of those comments as documentation
so I started talking to a lot of Newark
programmers you know as I started
mentoring and I was watching a lot of
them making these comments to themselves
as they go along and I said well you
know why are we doing that a lot of and
I found you know people are doing this
for a lot of different reasons they were
perhaps describing functions someone
mentioned earlier there might be you
know an unclear decision or tricky
and then or you might have something at
the top of a file to help orient people
if they're into a new Co base explaining
the purpose all these helper functions
do broadly this and tie in so that you
don't have to like follow those calls
you might also be using this a little
bit as a note pad or it may guide your
future Doc's like if you find oh we keep
running into problems around these
sections maybe we need to have a whole
section on that in our long-form dots so
with all these like pretty good reasons
for using comments you'd think we'd be
throwing them willy-nilly everywhere
right but what's a what's a problem that
they're not centralized what's another
column of comments people have to write
them human beings gross um anything else
people comment differently there's one
more that I'm really surprised hasn't
come out yet cuz when I go on the
internet and I ask about comments people
scream at me they say I'm God the god of
programmers and like you know if you
don't understand my code you should just
like you know go home and whatnot so I
hear I hear a bunch there are a bunch of
problems but comments they they think I
have a bad rap um I'm a little stick
figure version of myself you know here's
you know comments mean it's time to her
factor you better keep it dry that's
don't repeat yourself the coach just
b-before itself and comments rot why are
we even putting them there um so one
thing that I wanted to address here it
is a really good point the the thing is
is there's like a bit of truth in each
of these statements like comments that
are left unattended they do rot they do
mislead it's ugly um and you know
possibly if you're seeing a lot of
comments in an area it is time to
refactor but when when do we end up
refactoring um often in our workplaces
depending on what stage we're at in what
stage are
and Sara we might feel that this this
new work that we could be doing like
build those features is like a lot given
a lot more time and a lot more airtime
and um you know is looked better on as
far as promotions going all of that then
doing the like I made it better work
like I deleted code we know that's good
but you know sometimes it doesn't seem
to come across like that um so it may
feel like a nice-to-have and so you know
I start wondering you know is
refactoring in a sense a programmers
version of self-care instead of part a
big part of their day so you might you
might feel a little bit like this like
you know to get into a factoring um and
the problem the real problem here is you
may have written code two years ago and
you keep thinking like oh I've gotta
like go back and fix it and like clean
it up but by the time something has been
written two years ago you might need to
draw yourself a bubble bath just to calm
down thinking about like how much like
digging into it you're gonna have to do
two to do that and obviously you don't
want a computer to be in the same tub
with water and I don't know why this
person is doing it it's just not a good
a good scene and so we're factoring we
need to like you know find a way to
bring that on you know beyond a you know
act an act of self-care um and going
back to our comment that a comic that I
started us off with if we consider these
rotten comments that we always work
worried about in the context of this
comment comic it takes on a different
meaning so not only is it just like you
need Docs to support your community and
Doc's are super important but also
having Doc's that are updated mislead
and it's going to like lead someone down
the wrong path at which point they have
a pretty good reason to string you up by
your tie so you know if we you know felt
bad for our lizard at the bottom that
was about to get this stuffing knocked
out of him like maybe we feel a little
less bad now um and there have been real
losses that could have been avoid
avoided by a well-placed comment in my
research
someone told me about an incredible loss
of data that was literally due to it dev
changing a value unknowingly within a
code base something that wasn't um you
know that that passed the test that
probably shouldn't have and um you know
at you know hearing that story I said
you know would that would have been a
good place for a Claire you know for a
comment that said like hey you know the
like you are above hot lava level you
know with explanation points everywhere
like um should should that have been
been there instead and especially as
someone who's self-taught and kind of
figured out how programming works as I
went along you know I run and ran into
this a lot who has asked the internet
for advice we're all programmers we have
probably at some point had to ask the
internet for advice and sometimes they
say really conflicting things like you
know my my favorite was you know I was
hearing like you know got to keep it dry
I'm the god of programming I shouldn't
have to explain it to you my codes so
clear and you know but we know on the
other side of that that undocumented
code you know as seen in our previous
comic it's pretty unusable so you know
my smiley face turned upside down and we
were really really sad um and it left me
in a position where I was trying to
figure out what style is best for me and
on the way I wrote some really ugly code
so are you ready to see some really
horrible ugly code we're gonna play a
fun game it's called critique those
comments so in our first example I
started you know this project started as
a tutorial and I said hey I want you to
know recruiters that I didn't write this
fully myself I'm not sure in a rover
area so like here's the tutorial that I
started off it's right there see and so
you can go and you can be like okay she
added all these features she did all
these cool things with it but she did
have this
like to start off with does do people
think that's like a reasonable comment
to have at the top of a file it's okay
to yell at me this this is like past me
she doesn't even mind anymore remember
where the cocaine from maybe you know
it's based on an API and something in
the API is changed I know of at least
one tutorial that you know what expected
that Twitter API to be a certain way and
then you know um so yeah that that could
be a really good point nobody else has
opinions yeah that's exactly where I was
coming from so I spent you know a good
many years doing academic work and
academic programming before I shifted
over so in my heart whenever I copy
paste anything I've literally you know
I've literally added like this is where
on stackoverflow it came from both so
that I could go back and see if there
was some nuance to the question I was
missing or if I like needed some more
clues as to what the code was actually
doing and also because I didn't want
people to think that that was mine um
and like that that's where that's where
my where my heart is um so it sounds
like a good number of us in this room
think this is like pretty okay but let's
let's take a let's take a look at this
so um back in the day I worked at MIT
and they're really nice folks and I
worked in a green building in about 100
feet from my building there was a
student-run climbing wall no you all
know the thing about students right
we're like they come in at 2 p.m. and
they're like ok we're gonna have the
climbing wall open for one hour and they
like update the schedule and if you
happen to see it hooray
so basically either all their friends
get to go climbing and Veronica misses
out or she needs to find some way to
like scrape or or ping the ping the
website so I was like well
they're not gonna let me like have
access to their servers whatever so I
guess I'll just scrape and I do a little
like check in periodically and then I'll
have it send me an email such a good
idea it was my first time using
beautifulsoup
anybody love and use beautiful soup in
here that's super here's probably so
much better at than I was and I was
trying to figure out how to use this
beautiful library and I apologize that
the comments are grayed out or anything
um but you know I'm I did some things
here I made I gave myself some just to
do's I said I want to open the target
with the selector here's the line
that'll do it I had some non-working
code then I commented out because I
couldn't quite get rid of it because I
might write some even worse non-working
code after the working code that I
comment at and I know I know there's
version control but was I using that at
the time I don't even remember anyway
and then there is you know I have my
favorite comment of all time here I'm so
surprised you all aren't laughing and
that's it you know you can see where I'm
going here should I escape the you or is
it just love that it's there I don't
know what was going on I was really
happy it was a list I really needed it
to be a list and so if you weren't you
want to contribute to a code base like
if you were work down the hall from you
and you were like oh I want Veronica's
like you know climbing wall open
notification system to be even better
all and then you open this up what would
you do yeah you make that man noise and
you'd run off the room you would get
away as quickly as possible and start
your own project because this is
illegible it confuses me right now and I
wrote it so this is not something any
programmers
to look at and like one could argue that
maybe a programmer wasn't even writing
it like what is that would someone want
to leave something like that um so what
what makes someone a programmer who
agrees that air air guitar on a keyboard
might be a very important element um
okay a few people look I don't know what
you do in your spare time but like okay
fine it might just mean me um so it's
really important that we know our
language and the methods that we use
whether that be with Python other
languages like there there is always a
you know our set of rules and best
practices and way of doing things so
like that piece of is important and we
need to be applying problem solving and
creative thinking you know thinking
about are we doing the thing that we
want to do and is this the best tool to
use it and then we need to like be able
to write usable code which I lacked at
that time um and you know there's a
whole question of the the the air guitar
thing um and we spend a lot of time on
that first point about learning our
language and methods um but I but I do
think that the creative thinking and
communicating pieces are just as
important and this is kind of like what
fueled will fuel the commenting jersey
journey maybe Jersey - I don't know um
and it's really important part of the
getting the mastery that that we all
desire um so I started getting really
interested in comments as I was talking
to newer programmers and I said you know
I'm seeing a lot of discrepancy in what
we tell people is best practices um you
know so we we usually agree that
docstrings
consists of inputs outputs and
transformation we can all agree that
outdated comments are dirty filthy lies
they're just bad um and I also hear a
lot too much
too much you know whatever that means
thank you thank you people of the
internet um and then there's all these
things that were we're less sure about
we say you don't want to waste
everybody's time the comment is the the
code should be the how and the comments
should be the why and the difficulty in
the variation that we have around best
practices for comments is that well it
allows there to be room for different
styles like within languages etc um it
also can be really confusing to someone
who's getting started and trying to
learn everything at once
so you know if you ask somebody there's
a lot of disagreement we we don't we
don't have the answer here um and I'm
really surprised that cat is that okay
with that image and it's possible that
the time spent labeling our cats you
know maybe at that point in coding
that's like what we need to be doing
like what is this doing really
maybe it's obvious to someone else but
you know if you are that human and you
go and you say hey Internet please help
I am learning and I need some help with
that they will say lots of things and
the take-home message is that only your
code matters and I'm I'm used to seeing
it but you know if we're really if we're
really honest with ourselves and this is
real advice given to me these beautiful
three words done you can all go home
everything's good right we're just gonna
code better it's fine so the advice is
refactor you got a code better don't use
comments only use the right comment
and only your code matters so it's kind
of like you know you're sitting down at
your computer and this guy keeps
throwing up his hands yelling stop and
like he's not telling you what you
should be doing instead
um so you know and I noticed that even
in like the most close-knit like
developer communities or people are
going to help each other out we're
moving through this together you would
have someone who has like you know three
months more experience six months more
experience turning and telling someone
who's slightly newer hey you're doing it
wrong like that guy and um and I think
you know I don't know if there's a
little bit of like I started wondering
if there was like a toxic beginner needs
to know a little bit more kind of effect
going on um but we're raising a lot of
Internet jerks and I got I got more to
say about Internet jerks so there's this
human and there's too many words on the
slide but there's this human that says
hey I have this thoughtful question I'm
gonna lay it all off for you and it's
all and it's all nice and I'm trying to
figure out how - like how many comments
are - too many comments can you please
help
and the response what do you think the
response is Blaine fulness I think I
heard like somebody groan it is pretty
much that this person says this has been
discussed to death how about you go see
this nice blog post from this like you
know famous jerk um and and the subtext
there this subtext there um that that's
not what we want to be passing around
that's ugly
so you know if we can if we can you know
get past the hey you know this is what
you should be doing new programmer why
aren't you doing it don't you know my
code speaks for itself huh and we can
really remember who who remembers when
they wrote like their first comment or
like what they wrote you know what they
commented out in that first week a
couple of folks a couple folks are old
and don't remember anything can can
those folks like come back with us and
just work with me here okay so I just
just work with me they're really magic
so you're you're telling the interpreter
just to ignore this and you could
right your code a love letter it would
be maybe that's how you feel like it's
fine um so you know if your paragraphing
next to someone and you're learning as
much as you possibly can as quickly as
possible and this person says oh hey you
could use a I can't think of a good
example right now it's on a stage you
could use something clever here and
you're like oh I have never heard of
said clever thing and you wrote yourself
a nice little note in the margins that
you can google it later and not like you
know ask in that moment because you're
already overwhelmed with all the stuff
you're doing is that something you want
to take away from somebody it seems so I
made a special slide for all the folks
that said that they couldn't remember
what those first comments felt like I
forgot that slide was there but I put in
there especially for you and effort so
these so when folks are newer to
programming and they're like taking on
all this new information um they they
tend to talk about it like this I don't
know what the [ __ ] I've done tonight
I committed a lot of things to get I
wrote something in JavaScript like I I'm
cheering for Diane right now I want
Diane to stick it out
and what happens if we tell Diane like
look I see you coding and that's cool
but you got to do it perfectly okay um
and like here are some things that I saw
folks using their comments for you know
references storage sometimes they would
have like a to-do list like an outline
questions that they were going to ask a
mentor when they could next get someone
to like you know sit down and talk to
them because sometimes that's really
hard to is like hey want to come over
and talk to me about my code I'll cook
you dinner and I'll be a total sweetie
about it just so that you know we can
sit together and you can answer my
questions has anybody ever had to gone
through that song and dance yeah a
couple heads nodding um where it's like
look I'll take you out to coffee I'll do
anything you want um so if only clean
comment free code is okay we wouldn't
have good stuff like this um so just
yesterday I was talking to a dev that
said you know as they put it they want
to get things working ASAP they do you
know like visual arts and like music
type of things so there's a lot of like
live coding in their life and they're
like I just want to plug stuff together
and make sure it works before I make it
beautiful so they they um since they'd
like to move fast and break things um
I'd like to do a little shift and say
maybe we should like move fast and write
bad comments um and maybe avoid breaking
some things so when they talked about
the comments they wrote they said you
know they tended to be like okay to do
like plug in this thing this thing will
go here and even I was just here because
sometimes they're they're live coding
and they know they want to change some
element and they want to do something
else and then go back to it and they
just want to pointer for themselves so
it looks horrible and silly but it's
what works for them
nobody's laughing because I already said
that thing earlier but like move fast
and write bad comments so I want to show
you some of my earliest comments but
none of them exist you know why because
somebody told me that if I were going to
be taken seriously as a developer
everything on my github had to be clean
code gross right has anybody else heard
that a few people are nodding their
heads and I'm sorry I want you just like
go back to that people tell them they're
wrong um and will I I have I don't want
to I'm burying the lede okay um so this
caring friend who was like my advisor at
the time who really wanted me to be
successful and um told me that I needed
to do this and I believed them and then
was so bummed out by it later the next
time I heard that somebody's commenting
style was an anti-pattern
I really couldn't let it go um so I
decided to take to Twitter as we do when
we're really mad about stuff and I asked
people I said how how about you were you
always dry and I'm very popular on
Twitter very popular so I got nine votes
on this poll and you know almost 50/50
if it had been 10m but it would have
been 50/50 but we'll never know because
I'm not that popular fine so I started
asking everybody about their commenting
habits and you know with those nine
responses I said well you know maybe
maybe we're saving face and you know I
extrapolate all these things and I was
finally like you know what I need to do
I need to make a real poll with real
results and maybe more than nine people
will answer so I'm about to show you too
many words on a slide and these are the
questions I asked in my poll and I'm
going to point out a few things
so I asked I asked some questions that
are broadly do be life comments and rain
do we not like comments in red and you
know kind of demographic some
demographic questions and what do you
use the comments for up there at the top
and we'll talk about the data in gray
and green and red because I'm really
interested like in the broad like do we
like them do we not like them anybody
want to take take a guess do we like
comments in my poll or not fifty-fifty I
think it's gonna be 46 whatever it was
with the nine people that would be just
too great so let's let's look at some
results so you know what best describes
your current or recent use of comments
and you know some 50 I think it was 57%
people said I really I use inline
comments frequently and I was like what
the internet says that's like a really
bad practice in your back um so like a
whole bunch of us are like really bad um
and I think that's super that people are
out there admitting it to themselves
into being and so as you can see other
people add these comments when they're
not certain what the code is doing when
at the function level many are using
them in line and a good 18 percent of us
are still you know you commenting out
that unused code so like don't feel too
ashamed so when do we add these comments
we tend to do them as we're
experimenting and when others um feel
misunderstand so if you're pairing with
somebody and they're like whoa what's
going on there
we just throw it in right there and it
stays um and so I asked on a scale of
one to ten comments help me remember
what my code does agree or disagree and
I'm sorry I didn't label this super well
ten is I strongly agree and one is like
nay so you know forty percent are like
oh hey we pretty strongly agree and then
the tale happens I ask comments help me
clarify my thinking and we have about
the same shape commas can save current
and future developers time everyone's
like yes we know and then I had to ask
for my past self comments are helpful to
an individual contributor building a
project but should be deleted before the
project is shared and those those of you
who also got my you know had the same
advice when they were um this is this is
not what the community believes is true
you can add your comments willy-nilly
and however it feels best to you from
now on
um and then function level comments are
acceptable but inline comments are
clutter and you know things things start
to spread out here we're like no we
actually really like those inline
comments we told you for Veronica why
did you ask a second time I imagine they
were thinking because there's a fair bit
of disagreement and then I asked the
real moneymaker clearcoat is self
documenting and doesn't need those
comments at all and look at that lack of
consensus we just can't decide remember
our nice tales from before I miss data
that has a clear answer so I started to
think like maybe we should just be
ignoring the internet jerks and we
should work you know spend our time
saying like I'm going to develop the
commenting style that works for me um
and my favorite thing in the whole world
right now is folks that put ASCII art
within their comments to be like hey you
know I have like this state machine it's
really complicated and maybe you need a
nice little you are here and if you
think this is fabulous there's an ASCII
art generator right here so you could do
a little like copy paste number
and thinking of this more broadly I saw
I I saw this quote um and it kind of
struck me that like when were when we're
making software it's it's it's
interesting to see what kind of problems
were solving and how we're solving them
like as another like level more abstract
than like what and why are we doing it
like going a little further into that
why um
and so if I had to write a really really
tweetable comment about that I would say
you know in in a sense it's like what we
draw in the margins um is going to be
showing us is going to be closer
approximation to like where we are at as
developers like what is interesting us
like what is drawing us to this piece of
software
um and what kind of problems were
running into and how we're solving them
um so what what can we do we kind of
want to remember you know Diane our
newbie coder that's just doing the best
you can she did some work in JavaScript
just put a lot of things up and get who
knows what's going on we want to we want
to support folks like I have some advice
um so you know if you can advise the
current version of the person you're
talking to and say hey I see that you
did this thing and it's probably not
what you'll want to do forever but I see
your problem solving it can be a lot
more affirming than just being like you
know to be a real programmer and you got
to do it in that voice - it's it's like
pretty important cuz that's the
programmer voice um so it's always
suggesting a deep dive in reading others
code a lot of folks suggested the book
clean code as like a thing that changed
their mind about coding and we talked
about some of the like numerical data
that came out of this survey but I asked
several open-ended questions and
interest it was really interesting to me
that people would write you know I I got
like almost half page responses that
started out like
when I was a child I believed this about
documentation and coding and now that
I've like you know used five different
languages and seeing all these things
it's like evolved in this way and I'm
like that's amazing and if anybody wants
to talk to me about what to do with that
data I would be especially appreciative
and one thing I want us to all think
about is what happens if we were to like
rethink comments our comments kind of
like Docs and if we you know if we start
to say you know comments are Doc's and
we assert that would we be making tools
to make it easier to test our comments
to like make sure that they are
up-to-date to fix that comment rot um so
I'm hoping that we can move move forward
with some of those ideas um this is me
and I said oh God
so earlier I had a an emoji like a big
emoji on one of my slides and when I
tried presenting it um it like messed up
because Unicode characters are gross
sometimes and they do gross things on
slides sometimes and I looked over
really quickly my slide look a little
wrong and I panicked
but it's actually okay please don't
forget with me that was scary um so yeah
this is me if you want to reach out um
if you want to tweet out this survey or
anything it's right there please don't
take this survey cuz we all know what
happens when you show some of your
results to someone and then they take
your and then they take your survey and
the data sad forever and then I become a
public crying on the floor because my
data is bad um so yeah that's me we do
have a couple of minutes for questions
and I love to hear what you're saying
[Applause]
questions questions questions comments
wonder about other people I think one of
the things you know people who said
against example when you sit parameter
or variable you know that in itself is
not always explanatory I think we find
you know this is why we're setting it
this is what happens if you don't set it
you know you know put some put some
context sure yeah so we had the comment
about comments that it can you know be
be helpful to set you know when you're
setting a pram as a variable sometimes
it's a really good idea to to add a bit
bit in there yeah
I think that's a really a really good
point um her you know entry was a
stirring during a group project so there
was a group project she needed it and
they need folks right right
documentation folks don't wanna write it
got documentation me because we treat
documentation like a second-class
citizen I don't know um so like folks
don't want to do that and she's like oh
hey how does this work
you mean I just need to add this in so
the point being is this could be like a
really good entry for folks who are like
in that in that kind of situation I
think I think that's an excellent point
yeah and I think go ahead
yeah I think I think there's a lot of
nuance there certainly and having that
that bit about the how versus the why is
really important and I do think that
there might be a a Phase two of this
survey that goes into you know what
languages people are using and you know
tries to flesh out like comment types I
think would be a really important
important second you know second set of
questions to ask I think that's a really
good that's an excellent point and when
you when you look at a lot of folks get
started with like the line by line
tutorials kind of the like codecademy
type of processes where they literally
are like write a line that does this and
then you get the green light you know
and I think when people are in that
stage you know that that can be can be
really helpful
anybody else very thoughts yes
your person is probably so scary I feel
like there's so the there's a concept if
you know if we borrow concepts from
other areas of engineering and even you
know when we start looking at like risk
assessments within within code there's
there's questions of like urgency and
the amount of risk like what does this
code connect to like you know are we in
finance as you know is this you know are
we talking about people's money's or
health data etc like so that so there's
I'm trying to remember um I talked to
someone who was in mechanical
engineering who you know really quickly
pointed and said oh kinda we have he
there was like a we have that moment
like oh we do the same thing like
there's you know these like different
levels rose risk you can have I don't
run of the words right now but it was it
was good to good to see that thanks for
bringing it up this good point all right
um we are gonna have to wrap up but it's
lunch now so either get excited about
lunch or get excited about if you want
to chatting with me in this room for
another couple days so good having you
all